Bishop Robert Emmet baron is a us-based prelate of the Roman Catholic Church
serving as an auxiliary bishop of the Archdiocese of Los Angeles
He was a professor of systematic theology at the University of Saint Mary of the lake from 1992 until
upgraded in 2008 to the inaugural Francis Cardinal George professor of faith and culture
He founded the Catholic ministry word on fire
Which employs traditional and digital media to describe the doctrines of Catholicism to the general public?
Word on fire published the 10 part series
Catholicism which was broadcast on PBS in 2011. And which Bishop Baron hosted?
He's published a number of books including
Catholicism a journey to the heart of the faith
vibrant paradoxes the both
/and of Catholicism and very recently
Your life is worth living with Fulton sheen published on March 5th
He has a substantive YouTube presence with a total viewership of 30 million and is well known on Facebook as well
with 1.5 million followers
Clearly Bishop Baron is among the rare religious figures managing a substantial public impact in the present world
It's very nice to see you I've been looking forward to our meeting for quite a long time. Yeah, me too
Thanks for having me on the show
Yeah, well people keep writing and saying you have to talk to Bishop Baron and then they come up to me and they say you
Have to talk to Bishop Baron
Well, I mean the same thing from the other side everyone telling me to talk to you. So it must be in God's providence
I suppose
Yeah, so why do people want us to talk as far as you're concerned
Yeah, you know
I'm not entirely sure but I would say I think you've opened a lot doors for people to religion
In an era when you know, the new atheists are very influential among young people and I think you've opened doors that
Legitimize at least RIA Pro Qing these great issues and questions and texts. And so I I'm doing it I suppose in a more
Explicit way but you're I think paving the way for an awful lot of people at least to reconsider religion
So maybe they find that intriguing probably the fact that we're both
coming out of an academic
Background, but then trying to reach out, you know more widely through the social media. So there's that in common, but
Nice to speak for myself. That's what I see in you that's been so powerful
because in the wake of the new atheist critique, I mean
I just find that so
such a desert opens up for young people and and I deal with young people all the time and I hear the echoes of
Hitchens and Dawkins and sam harris all the time, but it's such a finally bleak view
You know and religion speaks to these deepest longings of the heart and I think you for a lot of people made that again
Possible at least to think coherently and rationally about those things
so I found that very
uplifting and helpful
And I think a lot of people have to if maybe they see a point of contact there between the two of us
maybe you know, it's funny because
I've received
letters from
People of different faiths from all of the world think like, yeah
surprising number of people
Catholics and a lot of Orthodox Christians Lord of Orthodox choose a
Substantial number of Muslims far more than I would have ever suspected
Protestants and and and Longson and
Buddhists and Hindus who are
Following the
Lecture series are you know on Genesis back in?
2017. Yeah, also, you know a tremendous number of atheists. I would say
Yeah, they probably outnumber the religious people surprisingly enough and they've said that the tact that I've taken
which is I
would say kind of
Balancing line between the religious and the psychological. Yeah -
But I guess it's it's had the same effect on the people that I've been target - that it's had on on
me
Like these stories. Yeah
Well, you know I've talked about you actually to the American bishops because I'm on this
I'm the chair of the evangelization in catechesis Committee
So the bishops concerned about how we propagate the faith today, you know
and I've laid out for them a lot of the grim statistics and they are grim about
especially young people leaving the Catholic Church
For everyone the join six or leaving now, we have the highest rate of people leaving
anyway, I've gone through some of those stats, but then I have signaled signs of hope and
you're one of them said the fact that this gentleman who's speaking about I'd say spiritual things and certainly now about the
Bible in a way that is smart and compelling especially young people is
hopeful
So many might be leaving you no official religion
But the religious questions have not left their minds and I think you're addressing that in a way. That's very
Provocative and compelling and it's given me a sort of renewed courage to say well, why can't we do the same thing? Why have we?
It s our book. I mean, let's face it
The Bible is the book the churches, you know produced as it's the heart of the church's life
But why isn't it someone who's at least in a formal sense outside the church?
Doing a better job than we are at explicating and so I take it to be a state of whole
Person mystery. Well, I feel to
that
my position
outside
The church. Yeah is actually critical to the success of what I'm doing
You know people who have tried to pin me down
multiple times with regards to my
Belief in God. I actually did a two hour lecture in
This was a 70 minute lecture in Australia about that question because I thought about it law and a boat
I've always felt
Imposed upon I would say and boxed in when people ask me that question
But I finally figured out that I didn't really feel that
I had the
Moral right
hmm to make a claim about belief in
God
meaning that's not a trivial thing to
To let's say proclaim. Yeah, you know because it's not merely a matter of
stating in some verbal manner that I am willing to
Agree
Semantically with a set of doctrines it means that you have to
live
You have to commit to living a certain way
yeah, and the demand of that life is so
stringent and
So all-consuming
and
And you're so unlikely to live up to it
that to
make the claim that
You believe I think is uh,
To me. It's smacks of a kind of I
mean, I understand why people do it and this isn't a criticism of people's statement of faith, but
for me the
critical element of
belief is action and
the
Requirements of Christianity are so incredibly demanding
That I don't see how you can proclaim yourself a believer without
being terrified of
immediately being struck down by lightning or
Cosmic, you know, there's a lot to that
I mean there's a lot to it this story that I've always loved about
Origen the great church father whom young love by the way
I mean young saw the Church Fathers of some of the first great psychologists and origin sermons on Genesis Exodus
Are like yours in many ways Amana?
have you been reading him explicitly but the of
Psychodynamic and spiritual reading origins all over that
but the stories about this young guy in in Gregory who comes to origin to learn the doctrine of the Christians and
Origen said to him
First you must come and live our life and then you'll understand our doctrine and that young kid Gregory
Became Saint Gregory Sawa Turkish
He becomes the great saint of a church
But he had to get into the life first and there's a lot to that. I think the
Practices of Christianity they get into your body before they get in your mind
It's also true
I think that when you take away a lot of practices that surround certain doctrines the doctrine fades from people's minds
When I was a kid, there was still the practice around the Blessed Sacrament people
You know with genja flexions and before you entered the pew in church, you would genuflect in fact, they say that
catholics of my parents generation when they come into a movie theater
To see a movie in the rows of seats. They would genuflect before the guy
Ruffle, but see that means this thing was so in their bodies, you know
But that practice was communicating to the mind the importance of what's in front of them
Well, the same is true really of all the doctrines
You know God in some ways is a function of this manner of life
and so I've emphasized that actually a lot my own work the
Postmoderns who have influenced a christianity are very strong in that two practices
I mean might take Jordan is there's a there's a hundred ways in to the question of God
There's all kinds of paths, you know, one of them being just that ritual
the body
The moral life is a way in to look at the Saints and try to be a saint is a great way in
Jared manley hopkins the great Jesuit poet
Who was a convert under John Henry Newman?
So he himself went through this process of discovering the faith, but someone came to him and said, you know
I'm really wrestling with belief in God and he said give alms
Where's he didn't provide an argument reprove. He said do something
And of course if you play the whole thing out
I mean if God is love that's what God is
Then performing an act of love gets you closer to God than almost anything else
And so the giving of alms can it lead you into that sacred space?
Now the quest ding mind, I mean then wants to ask all kinds of questions about it and ground it
so, you know fitas cuarón's intellect him of an so might faith seeking understanding that's where theology philosophy will come in, but I think
Practically about
certain elements of
let's say
judeo-christian fundamental belief so from
you know, I
Spent I think two-and-a-half hours the first biblical lecture
I did on the first sentence of Genesis and then tried to take the opening chapters apart in great detail, but it's very interesting
Propositions from a psychological and philosophical
Perspective in Genesis. I mean I
Look at it sort of technically in
some sense as a statement about the nature of being mean what Genesis reveals to me is that
There has to be a structure to encounter
possibility
Or that there is a structure that encounters possibility that's part of that's built into reality itself
Mmm-hmm and that structure is God the Father and that
Structure uses a process and the process is the logos and the logos is something like courageous truthful
Communication it's the word but it's much more than that
and it uses that to encounter this potential and to generate order and
It seems to me that that's that
Psychologically akin to what human beings do with their own consciousness, you know
the the new atheist types and the materialist scientists
Tend to consider human beings deterministic organisms, but my understanding of neuropsychology
is that the only time that we are no deterministic organisms is when
Circuits for specific tasks have been built up through lengthy practice and can be run automatically
You know much of the time in our lives and I talked to my audiences about this
what we do is we wake up in the morning our consciousness reappears on the
plane of being let's say and what we face in front of us is an unstructured and
Potential filled chaos. Yes, and and our consciousness determines the manner in which that
potential
transforms itself into the
Actuality of order into the present in the past and and I think everyone
understands that we treat each other that way like we treat each other we treat ourselves as if we
are responsible for
What we bring into existence
That's part of our moral responsibility
We treat each other as if that's part of what makes us worthwhile as creatures
that's part of our value we treat ourselves as if
the nature of what we bring into being
Is determined by our choices between good and evil?
and
we treat other people the same way like you can't have a
friendship with someone if you don't believe that they have
that power of choice and that
capacity for morality
You're you you don't have there's any respect for them and they won't interact with you
and so you can't found a friendship on that and you can't found a family and
you can't found a
society or without the fundamental presupposition that
Individuals, this is another element. Of course
The presuppositions in Genesis, then that the individual is somehow made in the image of God if God
Is that which confronts potential and generates order and and more you know?
Because God says to in Genesis that every time he constructs something that's new and orderly
using the locals he says and it was good and that's so fascinating to me because it's repeated so many times because
what it implies is that if you confront if the potential of
being is confronted with
What's good and truthful and courageous then what?
Emerges as a consequence is good. And I also believe that to be the case for individuals if you
confront the world
Matter that's
cane like
Bitter mm-hmm incapable of making the proper sacrifices enraged jealous
Outraged at the suffering of existence and it's essential unfairness
Then you become vengeful and bitter and murderous and genocide all and yeah
That seems like no
Positive way forward. That's no bargain. Yeah
They demolished the metaphysics
Without really thinking it through I think and they leave people with with nothing. Yeah
Nothing is so empty that it it just produces
It really produces pain for people like talked to many many many people including
atheists who have been
vastly relieved to find some deeper meaning in
Everyday I deal with that is people that they feel obligated intellectually to accept the new atheist, you know conclusions
But then their whole soul is rebelling against it and I would say for obvious reasons, you know
It's variously meet Jordan is I got a colleague Chris Kaiser who teaches at LMU?
He's written on your stuff
And he said what Peterson is doing is what the Church Fathers would have called the trope illogical reading of the scriptures, you know
The four senses you got the literal historical interpretation. You've got the allegorical so it has to do with Jesus
You have the anagogical having to do with the journey to heaven, but the trope illogical they would have seen is the moral sense
So what it has to do about our moral lives and I think in our categories say maybe the psychological life, etc
And so I think what you just proposed there is a cool, you know, throw a trope illogical
Reading in those texts. I mean I without denying it. I'd press send the more metaphysical stuff
Joseph Ratzinger who became pope benedict xvi did a wonderful meditation on
Genesis saying that to say I believe in god is to say I believe in the primacy of law goes over and against mere matter
Is over and against a merely materialist view that what's more meta physically primordial is Plagas and he would stress
Intelligibility that the fact that God speaks the world into being means it's marked in every nook and cranny by something like intelligibility
which in turn would ground anything like the sciences, I mean any
Scientist goes out to meet a world that at least he or she assumes is intelligible, you know
so the the
Intelligibility of things that the rational structure within being is coming from from the logos
but the other thing that I think is really intriguing about the genesis that opening move is
The dethroning of all the false claims to divinity
So all the things that come forth from God, you know from Sun and Moon and and the animals and so on so forth
We're all things that were worship in various cultures in the ancient world
So the author's saying no no, no. No, these things are not themselves ultimate
They're not the law goes from which all things come but then the cool twist to me. It's not just a no because I
See Catholics get this because the way that text is structured. It's liturgical II structured. It's like a liturgical procession
Everything coming forth in this ordered way at the end of the procession I come human beings, right?
so at the end of a liturgical procession is the one who will lead the praise and so the point there this goes back to
Augustine and people like that
The point is none of these things is God
But all these things belong in a chorus of praise of the true God led by us
So and there's the human role is to give proper praise to God
Sukie yeah believes that
One of the sins of the judeo-christian perspective is that it gave human beings dominion over the world
and
The philosopher the German philosopher
If the narrow that window, yes
Phenomenologist Luther all
Know his student Heidegger part eager, you know believed
The judeo-christian texts had given us the right to treat the world as if its
Produce, you know there. Yeah, but that's six getting exactly backwards, isn't it?
it's it's this deep respect for our fellow creatures as part of the chorus of praise and the Dominion is not
Domination I think it's that kind of right ordering
and the thing there is there's been a lot of interesting studies recently of the temple the ancient temple and
How it was covered inside now by symbols of the cosmos
You know animals and plants and planets and stars and so on the idea being when Israel gathered for right praise
It was the whole universe being gathered for right praise now
Look at that in the Gothic churches, you go to no tree Domino that it's not an anthropocentric thing
you've got the planets and stars and
Astrological signs and animals galore because the cathedral was a successor of the temple the place of right praise and it's drawing
creation in
see
I think it's much more
Modernity that is rough on nature and rough on the animal kingdom Thomas Aquinas is not and we go back to the the pre-modern
Christian thinkers
They're not anti-nature on the contrary because the biblical vision is salvation is a cosmic reality
God's trying to save all of his creation. That's the Noah story is God
The Ark is like a floating temple, right? So it's a little microcosm of the right order of things led by
And what are they concerned about the animals they're concerned about life that God created that's why the ark becomes a symbol of the church
So all the churches are meant to look like chips
You have a nave right the ship the central aisle of a church
But they're meant to be a little floating temple where creation is honored and preserved. So no I I would blame
There's a tremendous emphasis on the idea that like Noah who's someone who
Like Adam before the fall walked with God he was capable because he could act
Nobly and courageously and truthfully and also put his family together. He's actually capable of shepherding
The complex creation of being in its totality
Right a period of absolute chaos and Brendon I look at
the
environmental
Challenges let's say that we face today
because of the complexity of
The nine billion of us or the nine billion that there will be in the necessity of making sure that everyone has adequate
Security and shelter and food and freedom. Yeah. I see that the proper
pathway forward to dealing without is for people to
put themselves together and to put their families together and the communities together and that the
consequence of that the natural consequence of that
Adoption of ultimate responsibility would be the extension of care
beyond
The immediate need of a social even and so that everything does depend. I
Would say and this is something I learned from
Young from you was that
far more than we think depends on the
orderly
Progression and
care of the soul, all of it depends on it and you know when I talk to my audiences
It's so interesting and I think it might be something that the church is missing if I could be so negative
well
You know, I've talked to about a hundred and fifty live audiences now about this sort of thing
independent of all my classroom lectures and I'll tell you I
Tell people I suggest to people that
The really the ancient idea that life is
Suffering and and that it's tainted by malevolence that there's no more true ideas than that in some
base sense and
that that's something that everyone has to contend with and
If you don't contend with it properly
Then you become embittered and and you work to make things worse and everyone understands that everyone knows that's true
and then I suggest to them that
The proper way out of that isn't the pursuit of material
satisfaction or impulse of happiness or rights from the individual perspective the adoption of responsibility and
I'll tell you every single time I talk about that. You can hear a pin drop and yeah
yeah, I believe and I think one of the things the church has failed to
Munich a properly is that
You need a noble goal in life to
buttress yourself against its
Catastrophe and I mean evil is a good example of that in the Abel and Cain
Story because he devotes himself properly to God and things work out for him
well
more or less it doesn't end for
Good is sometimes defeated by evil. I mean, obviously he lives a proper an admirable life and
It it needs to be communicated to young people, right
what's the signal the biblical key is always right praise and that's I go right back to Genesis 1 is is
When we give praise to God drawing all creation together
Then our soul becomes ordered properly and then around us a kingdom of right order is built up
In the Catholic Mass. We have that wonderful prayer to Gloria who is a glory to God in the highest and on earth
peace to people of goodwill and it's it's like a formula that if I get done the highest
Then there will be peace around me. That's the condensation of the Sermon on the Mount. Yeah
That sermon seems to see that sermon seems to me and I also believe it to be
psychologically
true is that
it's necessary for you to
Aim at the highest
Value that you can conceive of, you know, and that has to have something to do
with the
amelioration of suffering and the
Constraint of malevolence, it'll expresses nothing away. Naturally. Yeah
there's a negative and then once you concentrate on that and
Focus on that and decide that that's there your primary aim
Then things do start to order themselves around you because well everything that you see and do
Directs itself towards that aim, but that's this
Yes, this you I'd say strangely uniquely Christian thing is that we say, okay
The the God that we're worshiping the God revealed in the Old Testament
But then finally revealed in Jesus Christ as I'm looking over my computer screen right now. I'm looking at the crucifix of Jesus, right?
So my praise is directed to a God who's entered radically into suffering
not just the physical suffering but the whole brokenness of the world of
Stupidity and in cruelty and injustice and hatred that's where God is gone. So the God that I worship is the God who himself is
Dedicated to the amelioration of suffering or of healing the suffering of the world
But that's the way it's going to express itself in a fallen conflictual world
Right praise will end up looking like love looking like love for those who suffer
But see I think that's the mess to me the master theme of the whole Bible
Israel always goes wrong without exception when it's praise goes wrong. It starts praising the wrong things. So the money
They're in the same position we're in in the modern world were where we've escaped a
Tyranny of sorts. Let's say or we believe we have and entered into this domain of
untraveled freedom and there's nothing but
false idols calling to us from every direction and that's that that's the diversity idea as far as I'm concerned because
Unity is certainly as profound a moral necessity
As diversity there should be diversity within unity and I fight it all the time
You know in the church too because we bought into that ideology and I actually looked it's illness problem in philosophy
The one of the many but all we do today is we completely valorize the many we never see its shadow side
We denigrate the one and ever see its positive side
The one is extraordinarily important
God
Yeah, I think so. Yeah, it's the death of that over our community. It's the same thing that drives
constant thoughtless criticisms of hierarchy even though all
biological evidence suggests
you can't even organize your
Perception without using an ethical hierarchy because you have to select from all the things that you can choose to look at
those things that you value high enough to attend to
Yeah
And that's our point about worship, isn't it? What's the highest value to you? Everything else will follow from that?
Yes, if you read the Paul Tillich the great Protestant theologian
But he said all you need to know about a person you can find out by asking one question
what does he will worship and
Everyone, of course at me Sam Harris worship something that worth-ship what's of highest worth to you? Oh
Then your life will be organized accordingly
The biblical idea seems to me is if it's other than God you will disintegrate
On the inside and the society around you will disintegrate
As a consequence reading you like if the logos is that element of
Being let's say that's allied in some sense with consciousness. That doesn't confront
Potential and that does cast it into reality as a consequence of ethical choices
Then I can't see how it can be. Otherwise, then that has to be
regarded as
The ultimate value because it's the thing that creates
Continually creates the world anew and you know, we know it perfectly well that you know
You can take the opposite tack. Let's let's say I don't worship
courage and truth in the face of the potential of being and that I worship instead cowardice and deceit
And vengefulness and well, then we know where that goes
you know, we had the entire 20th century as a as a
It's the template for the whole thing we went in the template from from every perspective
We know every it's obvious. It's obvious
beyond a shadow of arguable doubt
that human beings as individuals are
Capable of generating something around them that is so akin to hell even
Metaphysically speaking. Then the differences is is is you have to be
PK you let's say to quibble about the difference and I do think there's something metaphysical about it
I mean these things that we see on earth
let's say
Seem to me to be reflected continually at deeper and deeper levels of reality. You know, I mean, I don't tend to talk about
specifically religious issues because I think that would in some sense compromise
that the approach that I'm attempting to take you know, which is a
conciliatory approach in some sense those who are
possessed by the scientific viewpoint, but curious about the religious point but
If you abandon those initial
presuppositions that the sovereignty of the individual the necessity for courage in the face of being that the
Moral imperative to struggle uphill with your cross towards the City of God
I mean people understand these things if they're explained carefully and they know in their souls that they're
True and yeah
And they're all over the culture that's been a presupposition of mine doing
This work is I tend not to begin with, you know direct instruction or moral finger-wagging
But I tend to begin with something going on in the culture and and you've talked about this
You know that the hero myth is in practically every movie you watch but I the Christian themes are every place
One of the most remarkable to me being uh, I just saw that TV
The other night was the Clint Eastwood's Gran Torino
If you want to see the best exemplification
I think in fiction of what the church fathers meant by the meaning of Jesus cross
In other words a move of self-sacrificing love that exposes evil and liberates those who are under the tyranny of evil
That's how they read the cross in a very clever way expressed in more mythic language, you know
but the ideas are very powerful and they're
Beautifully exemplified in that movie the move that Eastwood's character makes at the end and of course the as he dies
He's in the figure of the crucified Jesus lest we miss the point
Because I actually made a video
where I used a picture of of Christ delivery
the Sermon on the Mount I think and I put on 50 splits face superimposed it on top of his and
It was for exactly that reason it was that
The reason that that's exemplified in Gran Torino
Yeah, because I mean Eastwood in that movie is he's a very harsh character very, right
He's like he's like the Christ that comes back in Revelations, right? He's very very very
Judgemental, right and he cuts no one a break
except that he actually does like he does separate the wheat from the chaff and he's even
Interestingly in that movie, you know
he's
he ends up being more akin to the
foreigners who he hypothetical hates, maybe
Who's the Good Samaritan it's the same idea is the good
right becomes more family to these people that he hypothetically hates them to his own children because he doesn't Sam is
Ungrateful and unworthy and these new immigrants are striving to be good people. Yeah. That's a very interesting movie
Oh, yeah
It is and it was a good example of a principal one of my professors years ago said the once integrated Christian vision
let's say a
Reformation enlightenment sort of blew up and the pieces flew everyplace and they're kind of twisted and they're they're charred and everything and they've landed
Here and there and so as you go through the cultural landscape you see them all over the place
So there's a there's a bit of you know
Eschatology or there's Christology or there's the Trinity and so on but they're usually in distorted form
So that's a good example of there's the Christus Victor theory to give his proper name that christ is the victor over
Sin, and death. He's conquered the dark powers and liberated us in the process
there it is, but it's in somewhat distorted form, of course, but
That's been the game. I played a lot is to try to find these these
Merely common, it's Universal because yeah you
and this is of course one of the reasons that I became so deeply interested in archetypes is that
If the story doesn't have an archetypal foundation, then it's not a story means something made something a story
it's just a random collection of
statements or images and
so it has an archetypal structure and
You know
I think what's happened in the modern world at least partly is this fractionation that you've described but also something that a
student once made me think deeply through
She came up and asked me after a class. Well if these
Archetypal stories are the fundamental
The fundamental element. Let's say psycho biological reality then why not?
Just tell the archetypal story over and over again
And I thought well
First of all to some degree that is what cultures did for a long time
They repeated the archetypal story but in our modern culture
What literature seems to do is to take the archetypal?
Story and to bring it closer to the individual. It's like it's it's brought closer to earth
Almost like the Renaissance paintings brought
the divine figures closer to Earth closer to the actual individuals say that and the baroque paintings did
And so you have this meeting place of the divine the archetype and the personal that?
constitutes something like popular culture and
There's some utility in that because it's it it
reopens a doorway to the presence of
What's missing that's being closed by whatever has happened to the church over the last?
Well what?
150 years to
Accelerating
degeneration of the church over the last 200
150 to 200 years, so I see it as a good thing
Although it isn't obvious that people
Understand that it's happening
You know, I explain movies like The Lion King and Sleeping Beauty and so on to my audiences and they don't know that
They don't
consciously see the Christian symbolism or the Christian symbolism and works like Harry Potter, which is
Unbelievably deep symbolic structure. I mean she did that so beautifully
Goodness, three Bacon's of True Grit
So when the Coen brothers did it and they brought a beautifully brought out these religious themes that were not in a John Wayne version
I saw as a kid or even like there was a remake
Kenneth Branagh did Cinderella and you say it charming sentimental story?
But it's a deeply Christological telling and he got all that and brought that out
I mean so those are there for sure. I mean within the Western framework
It seems it doesn't seem
like I've been accused let's say
Although I've stopped apologizing for it. I should have stopped long ago
fundamentally speaking to young men
You know, I mean most people on YouTube or men. So there's a baseline problem
but
You know, it seems to me that partly what?
I'm
suggesting to
young men
is that there really is a
an
Ennobling heroism about the fundamental Christian vision, which is to
Accept with gratitude your privileges and your limitations
The privileges those are talents you have a responsibility to make the most of them
that's the price you pay for the talents the
Obstacles
You're limited being and you pay a price for being in the price is that limitation? And so you have to be?
Grateful in it in some strange sense for your limitations
maybe the same way that you're grateful for the
Idiosyncrasies and bikinis of the people that you love and then that your that your that your tasks
Extraordinarily difficult tasks. There's there's no more challenging task than to accept all that
you know with with gratitude and
with with with goodwill toward being and to
attempt to
Work towards making things better than they are or at least not worse
Understand that oh, yeah know for sure
But yeah
Let me press something here because I think all that's true from the sort of
Psychological and human side the hero's journey and our call to you know
Move toward a transcendent moral good etc to give ourselves for the sake of the other
We see and that's all there within the Christian and the biblical framework
But see what I think is really interesting where the fireworks really start is
That God has gone on a hero's journey, you know
so it's not just the story this this human being Jesus going heroically to his cross etcetera, but that
Strangely, it's God
going
Heroically to that place it's it's God going into dysfunction and whatever heroism we can summon is
predicated upon this primordial
Grace that was given to us, you know because the danger you know
Look, I'm a Catholic Catholics like faith and reason so we'd like to operate in both sides of that divine
So Thomas Aquinas constructing cosmological arguments. Well good. Those are I think they work fine, but that's from our side of the equation
We're kind of moving our way toward God
But the fireworks start with the God moves toward us God God acts
And grace is operative is saying I can't manipulate I can't control it comes as a gift, you know
And so at the cross of Jesus, it is Clint Eastwood. So there's there's a human being imitating
Great move, and that's indeed what we call to to become other Christ, but he's also if you want to press it
He's that's God. That's what God does God enters into our weird dysfunctional off-kilter world and
suppresses evil awakens our freedom and
That's when it really gets interesting. You know, it seems to me that
this has to do with this theme also popularized about
Rescuing your your dead father
Yeah from the underworld. Yeah. Well, you know if you take on a heavy burden
Of responsibility
Then that changes you it calls forth from you things that would never be otherwise called forth
it hardly because you encounter new things and learn but also because that
demands that
the psychophysiological
demands of the confrontation and we know this
Biologically turn on new parts of you that are dead genetically and it isn't you know?
there's there's an immense potential that lurks inside of human beings and it's it's a potential of
Unlimited scope in some sense and I think that that's
Alluded to in the idea that there's a relationship between
logos Christ and and
God and man hmm and that
the way that you
Become closer to God
in the literal sense is by adopting that burden because that
Transforms you into what it is that you could be and I think that's you know
You look the other thing you said that was really interesting. You talked about the
Fragmentation of Christianity and you don't you in the old Egyptian story?
when Osiris is
overthrown by Seth who's the precursor of Satan etymologically and conception Oh
Cirrus is willfully blind. And Seth is his evil brother and Seth waits for the opportune moment
And he chops Osiris up into pieces and he distributes him all over the kingdom
and so Osiris can't pull himself back together like he's still there in nascent form because there's no
Destroying something that's divine. Not permanently
But you can make it very difficult for it to get its act together for some period of time. Let's say
that fragmentation I think is
Has occurred in our cultures
the death of God I
Think Nietzsche's wrong about that. I think it's the dismemberment of God
not the death and
something that's dismembered can be
remembered
huh, what we need to do is to remember and
We do remember in our literature and our art and our popular culture
that's all a form of remembering but we also remember when we
when we act in a way that works in accordance with our conscience and that
sets our soul in
in into a
Configuration of peace, you know, it's been fascinating
I've had
hundreds and
Mostly young men I would say come and talk to me after my lectures and many of them had been in very very dark places
You know
Addicted yeah Olek
suicidal
Chronic pornography users capable of settling into a committed relationship
Vengeful
nihilistic cynical
And and and also possessed by a kind of inertia that made them immobile
enduring the most vital part of their youth and you know, they told me look I
Decided I was going to develop a vision for my life. I
was gonna imagine what things could be and then I was going to
Try to tell the truth and I was going to try to act
responsibility responsibly and not in a praying in public manner, but in the manner that
Began with cleaning up. My room. Say are fairly humble act and
And then then comes the kicker and this is one of the things that's kept me going through this entire hundred and fifty city tour
they all say
And my life is way better. It's like I'm healthy I my job is going well
I'd had three promotions. I'm making twice as much money my I I've
Spoken to my father. I haven't talked and talked to him for ten years. I'm putting my family together
It's like things good things are just happening
left right and center
Amazing stories you're in touch with the deepest rhythms of reality
It's an ethical movements a metaphysical move that as you mention the Sermon on the Mount of the Lord
I mean, that's how I look at it is it's not just giving you know moving ethical
Recommendations it's trying to get us aligned to the fundamental
Non-violence of things. I mean that the fundamental move of God is he gives rise of the world?
And so of course your life comes together
again, right praise gets you online and knits you back together that theme to me is really strong in the spiritual tradition of the the
knitting back together and the splintered self
That's what I like
You know things do you I mean as a psychotherapist you deal all the time with this but like in the scriptures
So you mentioned Satan?
you know us autonomous system is the accuser and there's a lot to that but the other great word for that the dark power is
the Diabolus right the scatterer
That the one that divides and separates and so the demons always speaking the plural in the New Testament and Jesus
Bringing them back to themselves back to the center, but that's that's all of us sinners
I mean we were all over the place our mind and will and passions and sexuality and body
They're all going different directions and then it's like orienting for people
It's very young using an anxiety provoking to be going in all those directions. Yes
I'm right and that's what do you want of us Jesus of Nazareth?
Have you come to destroy us? You know and the answer is yes
I have come to destroy this this disparate reality and knit you back together. So she
Didn't eat you for a second because I I'm gonna ask you about that. My conviction is
Atheists both old and new so the Hitchens dawkins sam Harris today
But then go back to the fire box and neech's and company that they're they're rebelling quite properly
against a
False god what I would carry is a false God the God who is posing a threat
To our freedom the God who broods over us in this moralizing and dehumanizing way the God who I would say is a Supreme Being
Among other beings all of that. I I applaud them
I mean that the Atheist old the new are rebelling against that
But it's partially because I think he I think Jung saw this in his own father
Right who was a Calvinist Minister that we got so bad at proclaiming the true God
Who is not brooding over our freedom in this sort of moralizing an oppressive way? Who's not?
Competing with our flourishing but you know, the glory of God's a human being fully alive says Irenaeus
That's the biblical idea or the you know
The burning bush the Father's love that is the bush that's on fire, but not consumed
well, that's the way the true God relates to creation is he makes it
Beautiful and radiant, but doesn't burn it up
You know
we're like
it's so many the Greek and Roman myths with it when the gods break in things have to give way or they're they're
incinerated or they're destroyed but the Bible presents this very
unique and
humanizing view of God and then culminating in in the Incarnation with God becomes one of us without
That's why it's so beautiful to me in those seemingly abstract formulas about you know
The two natures that come together in Jesus without mixing mingling and confusion
You say well, it's a lot of these Greek abstractions
But notice it's very powerful that God and humanity can meet in such a way that humanity is not
Overwhelmed and destroyed see that's what the atheist quite rightly old and new are
objecting to is precisely that false understanding of God, but
As
It's a very
Disturbing analogy that I've always thought of me. She played the same role as maggots - cleaning out a wheel
yeah, you know, I mean I ma'am he's a very sophisticated thinker and
Nietzsche's simply as an atheist I think is a is a is a terrible mistake
I mean he certainly had plenty of good things to say about Catholicism about the fact that Catholicism was an
anti
diabolical movement that united Europe United
under under the rubric of a single of a single mode of thought and
Discipline the European minded and he also had wonderful things to say about Christ as a figure
You know, he said what made you believe that the only true Christian was Christ and right
criticism was essentially saved
for the dogmatic structure of the church
No, you know I actually have more sympathy for Dostoyevsky who I think thought more deeply about this to meet you
Which is quite a frightening thing to say because Nietzsche is such a deep thinker but you know in in
in
the grand inquisitor
When when Christ comes back to earth and and is then?
Arrested by this Seville by the Grand Inquisitor of Sevilla of Seville in the Spanish Inquisition
You know the the Grand Inquisitor
Takes Christ into the cell and tells him why it's necessary for him to be put to death again
He says, you know, the church has worked diligently to
humanize the impossible load that you've placed on people and
To make it bearable for the common man. And the last thing we need is someone as
perfect as you and
Terrifying as a consequence as a judge because something that perfect is a judge
coming back to mess up all our work and you know, that's a sympathetic portrayal of
Catholicism I would say on or maybe Orthodox Christianity as well that that it had that merciful element that
the demand for perfection was was was was was
Antithetical to but then of course Dostoevsky has the brilliance too when the Grand Inquisitor leaves
hypothetically having
Having sentenced Christ to death he leaves the door open and I've often talked about so true of
Catholicism and Orthodox Christianity
Protestantism as well as that for all their faults and for all the faults that people like Nietzsche and Hitchens and Dawkins
Etc
lay at the feet of these traditions
They at least did preserve the tradition and leave the door open and that's not an easy thing to do over the course of centuries
I think the institutions deserve a certain amount of sympathy even though I'm very concerned that they're
Degenerating and disintegrating in a manner that doesn't look easily
forestall able
Can I let me ask you a quick question about the brothers karamazov because you know twice in my life
I tried to read it. And I think I just got bogged down with the Russian names stuff
So I failed both times. I got a little further the second time but then just about six months ago
I got an audio of it cuz I'm in the car all the time in California coming back and forth and
I just about finished with it. I love it. Love it
It finally just it's saying to me as this guy red thing. You know, it's
Amazing how powerful it is on audio. It's wonderful. Wonderful
How do you read first of all the Silence of Christ in the presence of the Inquisitor?
But then secondly his the kiss the kiss on the lips at the end, you know
So he sits in silence as this great accusation is is read
But then kisses him full on the lips at the end
Well, I think I think he accepts the accusation like one of the things you said about Christ in the Gospels
Which I thought was it was
indescribably brilliant was that
Christ not entirely, but it's presented as a figure of mercy
Hmm and you who was wise enough to know that and and he used religious sources for this idea that God
rules
with two hands with mercy and with justice because if it's just mercy then
Well, all it is always forgiving and you have no responsibility and you're an eternal infant
but if it's all justice then look out because every single
transgression you you
You commit you'll be held to account for in some infinite manner and people are so fallible that
Well, you kind of see that happening and on Twitter now, you know if you if you make a mistake
Of any sort at any point in your life
You're you're yeah
roasted over the Earthmen coals for it and no one can stand that because
Everyone makes mistakes. And so there has to be this balance between mercy and justice
you regarded Christ's return in Revelation as
psychologically necessary because
any figure of perfection
Has this element of the judge because the only ideal is a judge? Yeah, and so
you can't bracket that in the name of
because the master category is love right and to be
Sentimental about it love leads to will the good of the other so that always has a judgmental dimensions
because if you have a child or
Yourself? It's like and I felt this when I was a psychotherapist practicing as a psychotherapist. I mean Roger said well you had to have
unconditional love
No, I have unconditional
positive regard for the part of my client again
Driving toward the light and I am a cold enemy with that part against the part
that's trying to drag that person down and then I tell you can I tell you that an entire generation of
Catholic priests was formed under the Rogerian assumption because that's what what my generation got no
I mean
I learned things from Rogers and that whole it
Works in a way when I was doing pastoral ministry and counseling early on as a young priest
You know
that whole idea of just kind of mirroring back to someone what they're saying and giving them the I mean I get it I get
It but I agree with you. There's a severe danger in that if that's all we're doing with people
We're not moving them in the manner of a spiritual teacher
I had a student years ago said to me what we're missing from the church is
Yoda on our shoulders. He meant Yoda on the shoulders of Luke Skywalker
Instructing him and pressing him and telling him what he's doing wrong and how to get going
You know that we were we were all Raji reans me just were unconditionally positive regarding everybody
But we were through it's a great compliment see the other thing that it's made me popular among young people
This is so perverse. I have a hard time believing any of it. Really
I mean the first thing that I have our time believing is that
You know I can
attract audiences of
5,000 people and tell them that the problem with their lives is that they're not bearing nearly enough
Responsibility and that's where they're gonna find the meaning that sustains them. It's a pretty rough message
Yeah
the second thing is
especially with young people because the message has been v for 50 years and this is part of the humanists from the 1960s is
Well, you're okay the way you are
Yeah, and I think there isn't anything more damning that you're well a young person, right?
Well, you're okay. The way you are especially if they're suffering and nihilistic
Out of well, hi. I want to get out of this state
That's right. They want to crawl right out of their skin. And so you tell them instead no look man
You don't know anything
you're barely beginning your your your your
Suffering because in a sense because you are steeped in sin to an almost unimaginable
Degree, and I'm saying that compassionately right it's mentally and that if you want to put your life together
You have to start small and you have to be careful and awake
and if you do it carefully then you can eliminate these flaws in your
Character that no one's like really celebrating and Clint right light up when you tell them that disc right so strange
it was a real pastoral failure on the part of the church that as I was coming of age because we were we were
Reacting against maybe a hyper stress on sin. So my parents generation probably got that especially sexual sin
So I understand that there was a hyper reaction
But that is exactly the problems you ended up with a generation of Catholics that felt like okay God is love
I'm okay. Everything will be fine
So and there's no energy. There's no direction. There's no sense of purpose. There's no sense of spiritual struggle
No evil
Right. There's no real evil everything dealing with you know situations like Nazi, Germany
Right, right, but no that was a huge pastoral failure one was intellectual as coming-of-age
We became very deeply anti intellectual and this problem of a hyper kind of Rogerian
Raj Aryan ization of our pastoral practice
See, I like to I like Rodgers a lot because one of the things Rogers really taught me to do was to listen
Yeah, right. Yes advice about
listening and then
Restating to people what you heard. Yeah
so this with you that that's unbelievably powerful because it yes course you listen and but Rogers was a
Seminarian and he did dissonance with the idea of evil and the devil fundamentally and he fell into the trap of Rousseau
welcome, you know the idea was that people were basically good and that's just it's such a
devaluation of people to say that they're basically good because it's clearly the case that people have an
unbelievable capacity for
Malevolence that and to me that's that's heartening, you know
Yeah
like again
I can talk to my audiences and I can say you look you guys just
Sit on the edge of your bed and you think about all the things that you're doing wrong that you know that you're doing wrong
Wait way that you're leading yourself and other people astray those things will come to your mind
momentarily and
imagine briefly where that would take you if you allowed your
imagination to take you to where it could in its depths and everyone norms their head because they bloody well know and they say and
imagine just for a moment that if you have that capacity for
Absolute mayhem and malevolence that the opposite is also true because if there is that darkness and that evil then obviously
The opposite also exists and you and then it's also possible to make a case for people
to people that they can believe
That good has the capability of triumphing over evil, but you don't do that by minimizing evil you do. No
Maximizing evil that's right
I mean
I would say part of spiritual direction is helping people see what they're really capable of and I mean that in the negative sense
Help people to see like I'm really capable of some really wicked business and if I'm hiding from that all the time
I'm suppressing it all the time. That's not the thing because from now a religious standpoint you want to say?
Christ goes all the way down
Now that's the dissent in the healthy, but that happens in us
he goes all the way down in me to the bottom of my
Dysfunction and people like to know if they have ski or he could it's showing that dimension of life
But if we don't do that
Spiritually then they were not understanding the cross right understanding Redemption
Salvation that were healed by this downward journey of the Son of God, but he goes with us there is Dante now
There's the journey downward through all the levels of our dysfunction till you find
I think he's dead right about that. You find some
originating
Dysfunction so the Satan whose wings beat the air and create the you know atmosphere of Hell
There's something in me that it's generating all the different levels of dysfunction
Yeah, but until I find that I'm not going to solve it and I got to go all the way down
no, they don't Inferno is right is that
There's just like there's a hierarchy of good. There's a hierarchy
Right don't take places to be traitors at the bottom weights. Right? Right. Yeah, this is rude because
you know one of the
fundamental necessities of
positive interpersonal existence even with yourself
Much less or let alone other people is trust like essential trust
Yeah, and it's a form of courage. And another thing I talked to my audience is about is trust because
like we we tend in our society of worship naive trust by making the claim that people are basically good and
The problem with that and this is what entices so many young people into that nihilistic. Atheism. Is that
they're taught this idea and
Then they're betrayed very badly by themselves or by some other person and that's the death of innocence. And so then they go from
naivety to cynicism and
Cynicism is actually an improvement over naivety
but but it's not the end and then they don't know that because the next step is to
trust
As a consequence of courage and to say look
I'm going to extend my hand once again to myself or to my friend or to my family member
Despite the fact that I've already been
betrayed and hurt because by extending that hand again I
allowed the person the possibility of redemption and and I open up a space for us to
Rekindle a productive relationship, but that's predicated on courage and not naivety. I know that
it's like it's like
Stretching out a hand to it to a dog that's frightened and barking and looks like looking like it's going to bite. You know, it's
It's still the best way if you're careful to
To establish
peace, let's say with that animal and and
the problem with the betrayers is that they take trust which is
the most fundamental
necessity for interpersonal relationships and then they violate the very
Principle of trust and it undermines everything incident. That's why they're at the bottom of Hell, that's what catches and Brutus Judas are there
Yeah, it reminds me the story of Francis and the wolf of Gubbio Francis, you know
It's like a dream that story Francis reaching out to the animal. That's been that's been
threatening the town
you know and and frightening everybody but Francis has to trust to reach out to the animal maintains it and
then it makes a deal if you feed the animal then he will, you know harm you and so on but it's
Doesn't young save a lot of dreams aren't animals function that way of dimensions of ourselves that were kind of it
Well, that's that's a dream for sure because what again is that? You know, there's a part of you that's ravenous and
Malevolent and not being fed properly right and that's often because you're not attending to it
You're you're putting it in a blind corner
And it's it's acting out because it demands recognition and like people do this with their own
It's the power that gives them integrity. You know, I've had clients and I would say they were more often female than than male
Who had this particular problem, but who had a very acute and judgmental intelligence
Very very bright people, but they were also unbelievably
Agreeable and so their intelligence would report to them something that was not
positive about someone, you know, it would see around the corner it would simply hidden motivation and
reveal a
negative truth and the person temperamental II was so shocked by the revelation that
Instead of regarding it as a genuine insight
They felt that there was something wrong with them for thinking that way and then that's the same thing as keeping that ravenous wolf
um
unsaid it's like
the the particular client I'm thinking about I spent hours talking to her about what she thought about people because
She was a very pleasant person and it caused her a lot of trouble
She was far too much mercy, and not nearly enough justice and her insights into the malevolent
motivations of people were
Unbelievably accurate and deep. Yeah, almost completely incapable of
allowing that to be real
You ever reminds me of we eventually Coen brothers earlier. They're a remake of True Grit
Remember that the young girl in that who's just she's seized by justice
she wants to get revenge because her father was killed and she just and
People people are dying around her corpses are piling up because she's just going to get what she wants
Where she's bit by the snake, which has a certain archetypal overtone and she loses her arm, you know
But she's carried after the snake bite. She's carried in the two arms of
Rooster Cogburn, you know who's a lawman?
He's a man of justice, but you find out that he's he's also a man of mercy. He's a man of
deep human connection and
The the story is prefaced by the line. There's only one thing in the world that's truly free and that's the grace of God
I just thought it's that wonderful said the grace of God is not just mercy and not just justice
It's the two arms of it. She ends up. She's all justice
So the what harms missing brewster's got the two arms able to carry her, you know
But I think that's what we've been missing a lot in the church is the two arms
We become just too much for Mercy Church in a way
No, you're not you're not giving them hell
Yeah. No, I think there's something right about that and that's the Yoda on your shoulder
so he's there someone who's kind of pushing me and telling me in teaching me and bringing me on that downward journey like
The Virgil move that you're gonna accompany this person all the way down. Now the importance here's like Pope Francis is really good because
Accompaniment and the church is a field hospital. He says for people deeply wounded
That's really right. And we got to accompany people though all the way down
My generation got I think a very superficial sort of you know, everything's okay. God is love and you'll be fine
But that led to a lot of drift and see when my generation came of age and we got hit by life
I can testify there's a lot of my class but they left religion in a heartbeat because we got a very superficial
Childish one-sided approach but then life hits all of us inevitably and the religion had nothing for them
Yeah
Love is a terrible thing right incursion dreadful thing. No if you love your children
You you don't let them get away with anything right you come on their
transgressions and that's very
I remember
you know this situation with my son when he was about four or five and uh, I
Had a really good have a really good relationship
with my son
You know, I've always
Assumed that he had the capability to make intelligent judgments and expected him to do so from a very early age
Yeah, and you know when he was four
he was talking to me, and I thought he was lying to me and
I didn't know because I couldn't tell but you know
That internal daemon was saying no
There's something that's not right here and I wasn't going to let him get away with it because I couldn't let him
Learn that it was acceptable to do that or that I would put up with it
And so I told him in this weird thing
It's kind of like feral or it's kind of like god hardening Pharaoh's heart. I said look kid
Here's the deal. I
think you're lying to me and
We can't have that
but if you're not I want you to put up like
tremendous fight here to defend yourself
Because if you're being honest well
Then I won't know that but I'm not gonna back off because I don't believe that
what you're saying is true and
so I
went after him, you know for a long while and it did turn out that he was telling me something that wasn't true which
hardly came as a relief, you know, I
mean children do that and it wasn't a surprise to me, but
that love is if you really love someone you
You can't tolerate
when they're less
Than they could be right it hurts. And so when someone comes into the church
and
It's all forgiveness. Yeah, there's no care there. It's like them. What the hell are you doing?
Look at you. You're addicted. You're yeah, you're you're you're you're you're
Hooked on pornography you cheat on your wife. You're done terrible job at work
It's like you're you don't take care of yourself as like what the hell is wrong with you? It's like where's the real you?
Yeah the person
anyone
Who is subject to that as long as it's done with care, you know and not I'm better than you. It's the right thing
It's like god, man
you're
you're nothing like
You should be yeah and if you don't do that you're not willing the good of the other
In fact, you're trying to move into an easy space
if I'm nice this person who'll be nice to me, and we'll all be happy, but that's not
At the beginning of the inferno when Dante you know, he sees the hill with light on it
Oh there that's that's where I need to go. I know I'm lost
I'm in the wood, but that's where I need to go it off. He goes with then he's blocked by the three animals, right?
That's a wolf and the leopard and the line I think
So there's no easy route as the point
There's no easy route to that hill you've got to go down and all the way down
I think we we probably did tell our people that there's two easier route, you know, everything's okay
You're okay god is love but then everyone what is love and love is nice love is harsh and dreadful, right? That's the
thing but
Right and they'll find out soon enough at the road is blocked everyone does but then what's the way forward and there should be
spiritual masters in place
That know exactly what to do the Virgil move. I know what we got to do here
We got to do a searching moral inventory and go all the way down
That's the descent before the ascent, right? You know, right because that's a classical form of man story
It's the story of Exodus is it's part of the reason that people aren't enlightened. It's that if you're gonna go up man
every up is
predicated by a down of equivalent magnitude right because look if you're if you're gonna improve
you're gonna discover that you're wrong about something first and
Then to be wrong about something means you're going to fragment and it's going to be painful
to recognize the fact of that error to recognize the consequences of that error across your life to have to
Reformulate yourself so that that error is no longer
Acting out as as part of your personality in your life. It's it's
Unbelievable dissent yeah
That's another thing that that this is part of the reason why for all the respect I have for Joseph Campbell
You know Campbell says follow your bliss
that is certainly not something that young said because you said
You'd search out what you're most terrified of and what you're most disgusted by and the place you least want to go
Where you have to bow the lowest and that's the place where salvation might be found. And that's like I
Believe that's true, and I believe it's terrifying
the the pathway to
Redemption is through recognition of error not through bliss
Ravens
Where Campbell got enamored of a kind of mindless Buddhism? Yeah
The only way up is down and that's that's in all the spiritual teachers or it go back to Origen
You mentioned Exodus, you know where he says that the Egyptians and the Israelites symbolized
The best of us is often in slow lane to the worst of us, honey
the Egyptians the slave masters represent the worst instincts in us and the most twisted and
Dysfunctional aspects of us and the Israelites symbolized he felt in our creativity our intelligence our courage all these good things our friendship
forward yeah
but the best of us is enslaved the worst of us and so you got to come to terms with who are the
Egyptians in you and they're making you do two things. He says they're making you build fortified cities for them
So we take the best of ourselves to build fortifications around the worst of ourselves to protect them and they build monuments
Hey look at me so I mean how much of life he says is spent doing those two
dysfunctional things defending the worst of ourselves and then building monuments to the worst of ourselves would
Get free of that and get to the promised land but I mean he was the original master of all that
Psychodynamic reading I think of these of these texts. It's also surprising that so few people know
what a
Multiplicity of readings. Yeah Bible has actually
Because we live up on this goofy fundamentalism, which is a 20th century phenomenon Scopes trial stuff and all that
We in America especially but in the West we got hung up on it
You mean Agustin who is deeply indebted to origin?
You've got these very creative interpretive strategies in place around Genesis
For example, it's not literalism by any means and that's we're talking origin. We're talking the third century. You're in a a second century
Agustin fourth century. These are really early figures and these are
Thinkers, right? They're not hung up on is the realism right? So I yes, we need to recover that
I think even as as Christians our own
biblical interpretive tradition
So, what are you hoping for in the coming year for you and for what you're doing?
Am I hoping for him
What would you like to see happen as a consequence of what you're doing? And what what do you think you are doing?
I mean you're on this public I wouldn't call it a crusade
But you're you're engaging with the public, you know in a new way and it seems to be it seems to be quite successful
Tim what do you think it is that you're doing? Right? And what would you like to see happen as a consequence of that? I?
think what I'm what I'm doing right is
Beginning with the Semyon of Araby is the Church Fathers idea
the seeds of the word the seeds of the word are everywhere or that's the bits of the
Fragmented Catholicism that are found in the culture. So I tend to begin with the culture and lead from there
I think that is more winsome
So I tend not to begin with a lot of preaching or you know
A moralizing approach but begin with a cultural approach and I think that's been more
Appealing. I mean if I wanted to my ultimate goal is I want to bring people to faith in Christ in the Catholic Church
I mean, that's my ultimate goal. I'm an evangelizer, but I'm using certain methods to try to draw people to that point
realizing that there's an awful lot of
Obstacles in the way, you know, I'm trying to kick open some doors
I'm trying to part of it is to help people with their intellectual blocks. There's so many especially younger people
They're just stuck
Because certain intellectual objections have occurred to them and they heard them from their university professors or whatever
To clear up some of that to knock over some of those obstacles that's part of it
But then to open up and I think that's what you're doing to I mean open up the richness of this spiritual tradition
Because it makes people it's not just an intellectual
Feast it saves your soul, you know, that's what I want to do. I want to help people
You know your fellow Canadian Charles Taylor the great Catholic philosopher
Talks about the buffered self the self that's caught in his little space and there's no sense of a link to the transcendent
That's what I'm trying to do
I'm trying to knock holes in the in the buffer itself and let in some light from a higher, you know dimension of reality
So I mean ultimately is to bring people to salvation and say so I want to do
But knock some holes through the buffer itself. I want to keep doing that
And I said this I was in in Rome and I told where we're this month-long Synod with the Pope on
Young people and I was elected to go to that Synod and it was interesting
you know, what's our strategy for reaching young people and I said
I think a miracle of Providence right now is we have this massive problem of young people leaving
But we have this new tool of the social media
Which we didn't have I mean heck 10 years ago
We couldn't do this
but now we can reach out to young people into their space because it's Catholic we tend to say what
Programs can we develop you know lecture series that we can develop what people are coming to our institutions for all kinds of reasons
But we can sort of move into their space with the social media
So that's kind of how I see what I'm up to and you know trying to do
With all those beautiful cathedrals
Yeah, well, that's um, I wrote about them years ago. I studied in parents
I studied in Paris and I used to give tours at Notre Dame and I was a doctoral student
I was a priest but a doctoral student and we were told by the tour guides now don't talk about religion
we were just meant to talk about you know, how tall the building was and what it was fill but I used it to
sermonize really to talk about the Christian faith and
I've written a little book on the spirituality of the
you know, I'd like to I'd like to read that I mean
Is there a decent bibliography in that book? Because I know?
Cathedral architecture
Knowin, I am to the little I broke this years ago is a little book of kind of spiritual meditation
So it wouldn't be you know with a academic apparatus
But I read a lot of those books at the time and loved the cathedrals too because they're they're just talk about you know
Like moving into a dream space of archetypal realities are all over the place
Chart is my favorite place in the world. Maybe my favorite
Covered space in the world is Chartres Cathedral?
I
Don't think anything is richer. I'm ever spending a weekend there. I went down from Paris on a Friday
Just got a hotel room and I stayed there till Mass on Sunday and I made sure I saw everything in it
I walked all around the outside all over the inside and
The my old testament imagination was so engaged by shark, you know
Because there's your thing about the the allegorical they read the Old Testament in constant relation to Christ, you know as the fulfillment
And the sculpture the sculpture is just incomprehensible
Are real medieval windows from the 13th century
Nothing sings to me more just a way it situated the topography of it
you know, you kind of come up to shark and when you go back behind it you
You take the pilgrims route up to it. And all of that. The pilgrims journey is implicit there, but the windows look like
They look like diamonds on him on a black velvet background
They're like tools and it's that it's the shining jewels of the New Jerusalem. So there's the anagogical sense
It's all about the journey to heaven and then the the labyrinth which unfortunately has been kind of co-opted by a new agey
Spirituality with the original labyrinth that most of the ones we see today imitate is there sure. Yes
Extraordinary I walked it what did several times and it's a very powerful
Experience anyway sure has all of that in it and more, you know
Yes. Well, it's such a shame that these
These buildings, you know, you see what happened in Europe
I don't understand it is that Europe went through this several hundred years long period of time where
beauty was
worshiped in
A profound way and see that manifested in the construction of these great
cathedrals that took centuries to build and they were these people were
Well, the bricklayer wasn't just laying bricks
The bricklayer was building a cathedral to go honoring God know which is how our life should be, right
Yeah, every little thing that we do should be imbued without higher vision
Which is possible if you have that higher vision, you know that the contribution of that
vision to Europe and to world cultures is
Absolutely priceless. I mean people make pilgrimages from all over the world to view these
insanely
beautiful and complex buildings and they were driven by a spirit that was
hopefully
unconquerable, but certainly of
Sufficient potency even in a fundamentally atheistic age to pull people in for reasons. They don't even understand just the
sheer
At what at the daring of the architects and it talked about a door or window?
Transcendence and that's a way of punching through the buffer itself those cathedrals and don't get me started on church architecture to last
You know like 4050 years when we largely adopted the kind of brutalist modernism within catharsis and built
What bolts are called that the great barns, you know?
These spaces and we wonder you know, well
Then why are the young people leaving in droves the church building itself didn't sing to them in any way?
Which they used to do even though we like imitation gothic buildings from them from the 1930s
but man a young Catholic coming of age at that time was
surrounded by the imagery of the faith and the whole narrative of salvation, and I was just an
Incarnation of stone. Yeah talked about part of the
Goal of salvation
Let's say to bring everything together to have everything come together
Kind of integrity and right with a kind of integrity in any union and of course music
Portrays that better than anything else as far as I'm concerned and those cathedrals were symphonies in stone
Absolutely
they
portrayed architectural e-exactly with music attempts to portray
orally, and and and it works I mean
It works. Oh gosh. Yeah, and they're comfortable has no belief
Right, absolutely. And you know, it's a bit of a cliche to say it, but the
Summa of Aquinas and the Divine Comedy of Dante are like that. They that same kind of quality of of
Integration and like the whole of life being on display and that's part of what fell apart
You know that we that we we needed the critique of enlightenment for sure
I mean I get it we needed that in a lot of different ways but sadly often that critique got overstated and we baby bathwater
Phenomenon and and a lot of the the integrity was compromised
How do you keep the critique without throwing out the substance?
You know
It's been one of the struggles
And much of the of the theology of the last couple hundred years has been so conditioned by the Enlightenment criticism
I mean I get it and take it in for sure
But don't so condition your theology by that critique that you lose all this stuff that we're talking about
Now that has the soul transforming power well
This is so necessary is that it's there's something
what's required is a re emphasis on the potential nobility of the human being and
and the moral responsibility
To make that nobility and reality don't even talk about words like that. Like I used the word nobility in my
Lectures and it's such an archaic word. It's like we should have noble goal
It's like who what child is told that now? Yeah, no
We're built for nobility
Well, you're a psychotherapist obviously
But it seems to me that we're so concerned about people's feelings and that the feelings getting hurt or getting repressed
Thing that we're afraid if we use that language of a noble aspiration or come on you can do better. Okay
You've got a serious problem that it'll awaken such negative feelings leading eventually to you know
Self-mutilation or suicide at the limit that were so afraid of that that were were reluctant to use the language of nobility
and yes, well, we're we're afraid of hurting people's feeling and feelings in the present and
willing to
absolutely sacrifice their well-being in the future and that's the sign of a very immature and unwise culture because
The rehearse should be the case then, you know
It's like look you said already there's no up without down. Yeah, and that initial conversation
when you lay things bare and you put everything out on the table and you discuss what the problems are and
Maybe the potential solutions now, that's a rough conversation
Yeah, you know it's it's almost more than people can bear but if it's a discussion of reality
Well, they're already bearing it
And at least they're placing it on the table
Indicates that well that there's someone who's willing to listen and it isn't so terrible that yeah like Voldemort
It can't be made right, you know, that's been exactly my argument
I alluded to it earlier that when you say ah
we got
Too much for people to take see but but life is gonna force it on them life will force them into this and then there
Won't be any wisdom or guide to help them with it
So if we say look I'm so concerned about sparing people's feelings
Heck life doesn't care what your feelings are on teacher doesn't care about your feelings
He was very theory and
I think this is a psychotherapeutic
Truism is that if you're going to confront a monster and you most certainly are yeah
Then you do it at a time and place of your choosing
Yeah
Because otherwise it waits until you're at your weakest and most vulnerable and then it attacks
and so there is no
Monster free pathway for no that's right to prepare
as a knight of christ
Let's say so that when it comes you're there or in fact
confronting it at its weakest point or you cower and you wait and it
devours you and then those are your options and we don't have the
wisdom of the kind of pessimism that enables us to view life that way we think well if we're careful and we're quiet
Well, the monster will avoid this completely and everyone knows that's a lie. Yeah. Oh gosh
Yeah, do you find this because sometimes when I use this language?
People say well, yeah, that's great for the young men
But the young ladies don't respond to it
But years ago my niece who's now she's what almost thirty I guess when she was about seventeen. They took her
I'm one of these these nature things, you know
They took the kids out into the woods and they had to hike and they had to build their own
Campfire and then they had to afford
Streams and they had, you know, some of these really demanding things where they were up against nature and up against life
Managed she come back
Utterly transformed as a human being in a way that religion had never done
She would Catholic all her life going to Mass her uncle's a bishop
There's nothing in in the in our faith that changed her the way that experience clearly changed her
Conversation
Ask me a question on my Q&A this month, she said that her friends are really down on her because she
claims to not be a feminist but even more importantly because she wants to have children and they're telling her that
Only an evil and cruel person would bring a child into the world
is terrible and and worse to do the damage to the planet that that child will
really do and people are very serious about this and they're very hard on young women and like I always think of the peda
You know because I kind of think of it as the as the Christian equivalent of the crucifix, you know
you have married there with her broken son in her arms, and I think that
The great adventure for women at least in part. This is the maternal adventure is to bring
into the world knowing full well that the consequences the consequence is a
Crucifixion like
Brokenness, yeah
and that it's still a mark of faith in the possibilities of being to participate in that and
Not to hide from it and to say well despite everything
I'm going to act out my faith in life and in the
Possibilities of being and I'm going to bring someone into the world who would be a net force for good rather than evil
And that's my moral
obligation and I think to present that to young women as a
major part of the adventure of their life, which is the truth is something that's
Attractive to form of them. They would be likely to admit it in today's
Time and age. Yeah, I'm glad to use the word faith there because just a couple days ago. We had the feast of st
Joseph you know and Joseph in the New Testament is like Abraham and the Old Testament is the paradigmatic person of faith, right?
So I was talking to a group of high school kids
And I said, okay listen to me everybody
I know you're gonna hear this from your professors in college and you probably hear it already that faith means
you know being
uncritical and you accept any old nonsense on the basis of no evidence that it's superstition and
look, we're against that I speak as a Catholic faith and reason we don't want anything sub rational anything that it's a
Lie, and and you know it that's irresponsible
Anything it's stupid. And you know it it's irresponsible to accept it
So that's not faith, you know, but I said what close what you just said faith in the Bible is this willingness to risk?
Under the Providence of God some great adventure. Yeah
Here's Joseph, you know they can
Yeah. No, I think that's that's it. And that's what faith means in the Bible
It doesn't mean oh, I'm an idiot and just tell me any old nonsense
I'll believe it means no
It means that adventure right? The other thing is that one of the things I really learned from reading the Abrahamic stories is that
The fundamental call is to is it called to adventure?
Yeah
easier to happiness and and even the venture the part of the
relationship with God that's part of that adventure is
Wrestling with God. Yeah, yeah
Itself means it's another aspect of that strange element of belief is like what is it to believe?
Well, it means to adopt this moral burden, but it also means to wrestle with God, you know, right and not to not to
blindly accept
Preposterous
Blandishments that knowing with any sense would ever swallow, right?
but I think we've been again pretty bad at
propagating that if the new atheists have got an awful lot of traction with that idea that religious people are just sort of naive and
superstitious and
Uncritical then we haven't explained very well what we mean by faith
With courage no, right and and but then under the guidance of a spiritual
Master that that will help you through that and push you toward the edge and help you navigate those waters
And that's Dante got that all of our great spiritual teachers have it, but we've not been good at that in my judgment, you know
Well, maybe we'll learn before it's too late
I
Guess I should probably stop with
Gosh, we have got one time
It was really a pleasure talking with you. Yeah, I loved it Jordan. Thank you very much. I do this delighted
I'd like to have another conversation a darker one. I would say I've been reading a book
Have you ready in the closet of the Vatican? Okay today I did agree. It's a bad book, but let me talk about it
I'll be happy to
More prepared for it because I'm prepared for it enough yet
I did read it because I figured everybody would be talking about it. And it's it's a bad book in many ways
Meaning I think it's poorly researched and all that but sure let's talk about it. All right
Well, let's call it a date. All right. All right, great. Thank you for having me on
well, thank you for coming on and
we'll get this up and out as soon as possible both in YouTube and
Foreman nice and I guess we'll see what the consequences are. We'll see you do find out on YouTube pretty quickly you do
more power to you as far as I'm concerned and and and
Thank you very much for spending the time speaking with me today. Yeah, god bless you. Thanks
Bye bye, okay